I ALWAYS THOUGHT IT WAS
DANGEROUS TO DRIVE ON ICE.
North: THIS CLIP IS NUMBER 1
BECAUSE THEY'VE DONE
SOMETHING TOTALLY UNEXPECTED
AND SEEMINGLY IMPOSSIBLE.
Narrator: INCREDIBLE.
WE TRAVELED TO LONDON
TO MEET THE ICE MAN JACK
AND HIS WHEELS OF WONDER.
ANY TIME YOU TELL ANYBODY
YOU'RE AN ICE SCULPTOR,
EVERYBODY WANTS TO KNOW
EVERYTHING ABOUT IT.
IT IS A REALLY FUN,
INTERESTING JOB TO HAVE.
IT DOES VARY SO MUCH, THE WORK.
I COULD BE MAKING
A 6-FOOT MILK SWAN,
AND THE NEXT DAY WE'RE MAKING
A GIANT ZOMBIE HAND
COMING OUT OF THE GROUND.
NEXT DAY YOU'RE MAKING
A CAR DRIVING ON AN ICE WHEEL.
I'D DEFINITELY SAY IT'S UP THERE
WITH ONE OF THE BEST JOBS
IN THE WORLD, YEAH.
DON'T PARK THIS CAR
OUTSIDE A COCKTAIL BAR 'CAUSE
YOU COULD COME BACK AND FIND
THAT YOUR WHEELS
ARE NOW A MAI TAI.
BUT IT WOULD STOP YOU
FROM DRINKING AND DRIVING.
WE REALLY WORKED IT OUT
AS MUCH AS WE COULD.
SO THEY HAD CONFIDENCE
IT WAS GONNA WORK.
BUT THERE WAS STILL
A DEGREE OF DOUBT
IN EVERYBODY'S MIND 'CAUSE
REALLY THE WHOLE IDEA
WAS A BIT OUTLANDISH.
BUT THE SECOND IT DID ACTUALLY
MOVE ON THOSE WHEELS WAS
A BIT OF A DELIRIOUS MOMENT
FOR EVERYONE, I THINK.
AS MUCH AS I ENJOYED IT,
IT WAS HARD.
BUT IT WAS IN THAT FINAL MOMENT
MADE IT ALL WORTH IT.
THIS IS THE CNC MACHINE
THAT WE USED TO MAKE
THE ACTUAL ICE WHEEL.
IN A MOMENT, IT'S CUTTING
QUITE A BASIC LOGO,
SO IT'S JUST
A TWO-DIMENSIONAL SHAPE,
WHEREAS THE WHEEL IS ACTUALLY
A THREE-DIMENSIONAL SHAPE.
A LOT MORE COMPLICATED.
Narrator: SO HOW CAN ICE WHEELS
SUPPORT THE WEIGHT OF A CAR?
THE TOTAL MASS OF THIS CAR
IS OVER 2 TONS.
THAT MEANS THAT EACH WHEEL NEEDS
TO SUPPORT OVER HALF A TON.
A BLOCK OF ICE
THE SIZE OF A WHEEL
DOES HAVE ENOUGH STRENGTH
TO SUPPORT THE WEIGHT
OF THE CAR.
BUT THEY DIDN'T WANT THE CAR
TO SIT ON BLOCKS OF ICE.
THEY WANTED TO SIT ON WHEELS
THAT LOOK LIKE REAL WHEELS.
Arney: BY TRYING TO MAKE
THESE WHEELS LIFELIKE,
THEY'VE GIVEN THEMSELVES
A LOAD MORE PROBLEMS.
THERE'S THE THIN SPOKES
OF THE WHEELS,
WHICH ARE MUCH THINNER
THAN SOLID ICE.
North: AND THEY HAD TO BOLT
STRAIGHT INTO THE ICE.
THESE HOLES AND THE PRESSURE
OF THE BOLTS
COULD CAUSE
STRESS CONCENTRATIONS
WHICH WOULD CREATE CRACKS
AND LEAD TO THE FAILURE
OF THE WHEELS.
AND ALL OF THAT
MAKES IT IMPOSSIBLE
FOR THE WHEEL TO REALLY
BE MADE OUT OF ICE.
WELL, THE ORIGINAL PLAN
WAS TO MAKE A FULL ICE WHEEL
LIKE THIS ONE.
BUT OBVIOUSLY, AS YOU CAN SEE,
IT'S QUITE DELICATE
IN THE CENTER.
SO WE ACTUALLY USED
TWO FACADES OF ICE
THAT CLAMP
ONTO THIS ACRYLIC RIM.
THIS WAY THE ACRYLIC
WAS CARRYING THE BULK
OF THE LOAD OF THE CAR.
IN FACT, ACRYLICS
COMPRESSIVE STRENGTH
CAN BE 10 TIMES STRONGER
THAN THAT OF ICE.
AND OBVIOUSLY IT
WAS CRYSTAL-CLEAR,
SO YOU BARELY NOTICED IT WAS
THERE IN THE FINAL SHOT,
WHICH WAS GREAT.
YOU COULD SAY THEY'RE CHEATING,
BUT I THINK THEY'VE TAKEN
SOME BRILLIANT PHYSICS
AND USED IT TO CREATE
AN INCREDIBLE SPECTACLE.
NICE JOB, GUYS.